I promise you [__] I album you've been
patiently waiting now today is finally
present I took my time with this [__] I
put my mind into every line cuz when
inside I ain't trying to regret it
[__] get overhyped and all the hits
ghost it's like you you're just an
honest [__] gun man like if you
if you don't [__] with someone or
something's wack like a lot of people
are very politically correct yeah
they're worried about you know ya
burning bridges yeah don't kid about
burn bridges and my connection is just
with the fans so it doesn't matter to me
like I just I just make the music I got
my Facebook page that got my little
YouTube channel I'm good
hi I can sue these shows and yeah I
don't care about burning bridges I just
speak my mind I'm allowed to I feel like
like in the video you ripped Kanye and
you being a short guy
the kendrick thing like I feel like you
and Kendra can like work together cuz
he's dead no can't kid I guess though I
think I think I know but honestly the
like the kind of thing he does I'm a fan
of Connie's older stuff so it's not like
oh hey at the other day is hip-hop yes
it on that guy and he were the guy to do
it
I'm the guy you know a lot Rob people
won't acknowledge me because I'm so I'm
so underground to where I don't know I'm
not a butylated with any you know
anybody saw and they and they I don't
give a [__] so much to where and
enormous a everybody has this mentality
my some rappers if I have say some
bottle they know that I don't give a
[__] so much to her I'm the guy who will
literally go all out to smash them and
they will get a million views in 24
hours if they were really really push me
to that point and I don't know
they fight like I you know I'm not
trying to do all that all right and
they'll probably be like you know what
I'm Way bigger than this guy even though
he does that lady's face he's still
underground I'm just not good enough
right it's a it's a good healthy balance
between them because if they acknowledge
me that had a meal like a [__]
soldier boys yeah and there's a chance
that their fans might like my sister and
you're so much more relevant that Soulja
Boy is they just bunny cuz I get the
time when you talk when I was fat he was
still kind of alien he's just like in
Oblivion and yeah but but at the end of
the day though man just all honesty like
it's hip-hop
I don't hate anybody that I'm ever
shaved thing about from from tiger
cleaner to glowing Drake Rick Ross and
any names that I've saved in songs it's
not like what the [__] I'm like man to
be a breath I come and it's like and I
will speak my mind but I'll never be
like man [__] your mom I see you I'm
appealing you [__]
this song some gangbang says it's not
like that it's just like I rap and I'm
just have you ever like like what the
kendrick thing I assumed you guys will
be in the same place at the same time
yeah you know I know I know if you lose
from black keeping all that you know so
I mean when I'm having heard instance
I've done that video I've heard anything
from them you know I probably won't know
I'm sure you know maybe next to you
maybe at rocketmail something right and
your mind might run each woman you know
I don't know how they're gonna react I
don't think what you said was like no it
was another my everybody said it was
MADtv if it was vice versa we're safe
can you say the exact same thing to me
and I was a nice person he said that I'd
be like sky but up make it show outside
here you know [__] clown this dude
try call it would just be fun like okay
I might give you bad weather we very
much like it's all jokes and games but
but some rappers they they really take
on their they trying to make it a
gangbang a situational I'm gonna say my
name nobody say my name
all of naked nobodies unrespected it's
like come on
he's the [__] horrible wife crapper
he's wet period no way around it he is
black in the dick in the dictionary
whack em enemies these to me he's the
best rapper of all time